[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory what
if I told you that beneath the
enchanting wonders thrilling adventures
and exuberant Magic The Wizarding World
housed an incredibly dark underbelly
because the truth is folks even a world
as magical as the Harry Potter Universe
has a dark side and today we're going to
be exploring just that from the
bewitchingly Eerie Halls of Hogwarts to
the cobwebbed chambers of grots today
we're going to be unraveling disturbing
theories that challenge our perception
of the enchanting world we once fell in
love with we will confront Soul shaking
questions about the psychology of our
favorite characters question the actions
of those we once revered and Ponder the
terrifying possibilities that lie just
beyond the boundaries of the stories we
hold dear and we're going to do it all
With a Little Help from our peers over
at the har Harry Potter Reddit page r/h
Harry Potter because today I've
collected for you a list of redditors
most disturbing Harry Potter theories
join me as we shatter our perceptions of
the Harry Potter Saga in the greatest
way possible and please take solid in
the fact that as bad as these theories
are I've spared you from some of the
worst ones let's dive in forgetful
Neville Neville's parents aren't
mentioned that often in the films and
they also sort of lead us to believe
that they had been killed by Bellatrix
however book readers will know that this
is not the case in the Order of the
Phoenix the trio run into Neville and
his grandmother at St Mongo's Hospital
for Magical maladies and injuries it's
here that it's revealed that Neville's
parents are in fact alive but were just
driven insane through bellatrix's
horrific torture in heartbreaking
fashion Neville would go and visit his
parents every Christmas to spend the day
with them despite them barely
recognizing who he is all of this
considered I think it goes without
saying that nville suffered an incred
incredible amount of childhood trauma
which brings me to the theory introduced
on Reddit the reason why Neville is so
forgetful is because the official
treatment in The Wizarding World for
childhood trauma is obliviation the
spell never permanently took for Neville
because he is after all a pretty
powerful wizard but the repeated
treatments left him with permanent
memory issues another Reddit user
commented on this Theory further I
imagine they thought they were doing him
a favor because of what happened to his
parents the obliviation Theory ties into
the possibility that he was the one who
witnessed them being tortured as a child
which could totally link to his social
anxiety as a prepubescent and his fear
of Snape specifically if this disturbing
Theory doesn't make you look at Neville
differently then I don't know what will
not only does it suggest that Neville
witnessed the torture of his parents
firsthand but it also explains his
unusual behavior and forgetful nature
reality of Resurrection we are first
educated on the resurrection Stone
during the tale of of the Three Brothers
then the second brother who was an
arrogant man decided that he wanted to
humiliate death still further and asked
for the power to recall others from
Death so death picked up a stone from
the riverbank and gave it to the second
brother and told him that the stone
would have the power to bring back the
dead according to the legend of the
Deathly Hallows the stone was created by
death himself and has the power to bring
back lost loved ones in the series ARA
uses it in the Forbidden Forest to
summon the images of his loved ones
however bone was initially thought to
bring back the Dead We later learned
that it only brings back a shade of
these people less substantial than
living bodies but much more than ghosts
and one Reddit user challenged the
function of the stone even further with
the following Theory the resurrection
Stone will always show your loved ones
the way you wish they were not their
actual spirits and they will eventually
or quickly in Harry's case drive you to
commit suicide regardless of what the
actual spirits of your Lov ones want
this disturbing Theory adds an
incredibly ominous spin to the following
book passage you're nearly there said
James very close we are so proud of you
does it hurt the childish question had
fallen from Harry's lips before he could
stop it dying not at all said Sirius
quicker and easier than falling asleep
this one feels dark poly juice problems
the poly juice potion which is a complex
and timec consuming concoction is best
left to hi skilled witches and wizards
it enables the consumer to assume the
physical appearance of another person as
long as they have first procured part of
that individual's body to add to the
Brew the effect of the potion is only
temporary and depending on how well it
has been brewed May last anything from
between 10 minutes and 12 hours you can
change age sex and Race by taking the
poly juuice potion but not species the
polyu potion is perhaps most notably
used by Body crunch Junior when he
impersonates Madi ey Moody and teaches
defense against the dark Hearts it's an
incredibly powerful potion with endless
possibilities and when I say Endless
Possibilities this Reddit Theory will
give you a better understanding of what
I mean I always thought there would be
some naughty uses for poly juice potion
like there would be a market for famous
people's hair so you and your partner
could indulge in fantasy another user
commented and celebrities would probably
make Bank selling their hair for poly
juice potion I have to admit that this
is not something I'd ever considered but
it does unfortunately seem quite
plausible the real Veil The Veil is a
massive ancient stone Archway that
stands in the center of the death
chamber inside the department of
mysteries conventional wisdom would
suggest that it acts as a sort of portal
between the lands of the living and the
dead and it's believed that those who
step through the veil or fall through
become trapped in the world of death AKA
they die those who stand close enough
and have belief in the afterlife are
also able to hear faint whisperings that
appear to come from the other side but
one thing that's worth considering is
that no one truly knows how the veil
works because once you go through it's
impossible to come back the whole portal
between the land of the living and the
dead thing is just based on
speculation and it's this lack of
definitive information that helped one
Reddit user come up with the following
Theory not a theory I heard but it's
something I do think of from time to
time time the fact that Sirius Black
never really died Luna had mentioned
hearing voices near the veil it made me
think that maybe the veil was patry so
Sirius who spent his life trying to
escape prisons and living in memories of
loved ones spends eternity the same way
nobody bothered figuring out how the
veil worked in the series so I can
imagine Sira spending eternity either
wanting to go back to Harry or to move
on and join James the theory essentially
asserts that Sirus who had spent his
life trying to escape prisons and hold
holding on to memories of loved ones may
be trapped in eternity in a similar way
someone did respond that if this was the
case that Sirius wouldn't have been able
to come back in the Forbidden Forest
however I'm not entirely sure that I
agree with that I don't think the shades
have anything to do with the genuine
spirits of loved ones that have moved on
and are instead as the previous Theory
stated false representations of loved
ones that try to convince you to end
your life HW Crux Horrors we all know
what a HW Crux is by now and if you
don't then I'm not entirely sure what
series you've been reading watching
hopefully not Twilight the shortest
possible summary of HW cruxes is that
they are objects of dark magic created
by a witch or wizard who wishes to Live
Forever by immortalizing a piece of
their soul inside a vessel of their
choosing however besides committing an
act of murder the entire HW cr's
creation process is a little murky no
one besides Voldemort and maybe a few
other dark Wizards knows the process in
its entirety which which leavs it open
to exciting and disturbing theories
which brings me to the following Reddit
Theory the real secret to creating a HW
rugs was that you had to eat part of
your victim after killing them even just
a drop of blood killing someone splits
the soul of the killer a spell is then
used to transfer part of the soul to an
object a hrug eating a part of the
victim is an act that replaces the Lost
part of the Soul with something vile and
stolen and allows the killer to live
without a complete soul because they're
patching it with dark magic in essence
this theory asserts that the murderer
must eat part of the victim in other
words the unknown ritual is cannibalism
there's lots of good support around this
Theory including the sheer fact that
cannibalism is revolting but for another
thing cannibalism is present in many
literary Works Through the Ages and
rolling has been known to find
inspiration in classical literature of
course there's the issue that none of
Voldemort's victims who are linked to
the creation of his HW cruxes had
anything notably missing from their
bodies although as powerful as he was
it's not out of the question that he was
able to feed off the insides of these
victims without leaving any noticeable
marks and on that disturbing note that's
the end of today's video what do you
think which of these theories was most
disturbing to you and what disturbing
theories did I miss leave a comment down
below if you enjoy these more disturbing
videos be sure to also check out my
series on the darkest moments in Harry
Potter I've done two parts so far and I
plan on continuing it and please if you
enjoy the content like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
[Music]
live